and Carol trying to post up here against
the shorter Knicks got a little one on
him
Baseline jumper with a fortuitous roll
not just because of where he was picked
because that's just his DNA yeah and I
asked Jabari pregame how motivated he
was heading into his summer league debut
as Ben Carroll knocked six okay from
three corner of the drive by Hampton how
about the footwork separation against a
very engaging uh young man and a guy
that like a lot of young players they
have some missteps earlier in their
career but it's all about learning he
talked to us about
improving his diet
one of the great questions that starts
being answered perhaps here at Summer
League here's Jabari Smith nice little
finger roll smooth in doing it so the
same thing we saw in his first drive
where it's decisive it's quick it's
mobile enough to split 316 to go here in
the third quarter this is the first of
two tonight Smith got it
he is a special shooter pushing these
guys willing to work every single day
supporting one another I think it's just
fantastic with this group of guys now
Jalen Suggs was with our Cassidy Hubert
earlier tonight
it's a discount type inside
and a nice look and find
[Applause]
[Music]
Carol inside look at his frame I mean my
goodness Big Time 6 10 250 pounds use
the frame the ability to get downhill
and the footwork stop Apollo what you
got in your game I got plenty folks
[Music]